when I say watch your language our words
shape the way we think and how we feel
and how we feel determines what we do
and what we do determines whether you
get results or not I'm talking about
being aware that there are certain words
that you use that put your energy up and
some that put it down certain words and
phrases start to limit you certain words
and phrases free You by transforming the
words you use regularly you literally
change your biochemistry your emotions
your thinking and your actions but if
you're unaware then these words can take
over your life and limit you without
even knowing it with so much certainty
that we begin to believe it and then we
look for ways to justify it and then
pretty soon we're stuck but you can just
eliminate the words and start to change
hey it's EV car Michael and I make these
videos because I need them because being
around successful entrepreneurs who are
pushing who are driving who are doing
amazing things gives me that extra
little motivational inspirational boost
in the morning every day to help me go
off and accomplish great things too and
I hope that this video gives you that
inspiration as well well so today let's
learn how you can create your own
reality
enjoy rule number two is be careful with
your words with Jordan Peterson you
should be careful with your words
because when you use them you're doing
one of two things you're either creating
what's good or you're doing the opposite
I know no one who hasn't been radically
successful who isn't radically expert at
communication and that also means
they're radically expert thought because
mostly we think in words and so and when
you write you're learning to think and
when you're using the language that
you've strived to master you are
literally generating the present and the
past out of the future in the direction
you're aiming at that's what you're
doing that's what Consciousness
does and so you want to have respect for
that rule number three is eliminate the
lack mindset with Ronda burn every human
being is a
Creator and they are creating their life
and we don't
know for many of us we did not know that
that was the case and we are creating
our life through our thoughts so it's
not that our thoughts are powerful it's
that we are powerful and so when we
focus on a thought and we really hold
that Focus that thought will manifest in
our life and so we create our own life
through our thoughts and through the
mind the Mind our mind is super super
super
powerful yeah for good or For Worse yes
so for example um we can talk about what
we want and we will manifest that you
know and so some people they just see
the abundance in the world you know
that's all that they see they don't they
don't see see any lack they just see
abundance and everything seems to go
right for them everything falls into
place for them they invest in this and
it's skyrockets and they they buy a
house in this place and that suburb goes
crazy and it's like everything they
touch turns to Gold but it's because
they have a mindset that is toward
wealth and abundance and they don't have
a mindset toward luck and we have a lack
mindset when we say things like I'm
broke I don't have
enough um I don't have enough to pay my
bills and you see whatever we say is
what our life will be and so if we are
saying I don't have enough money then by
law of attraction we will not have
enough money we will continue to not
have enough money so what we have to do
is we need to speak about what we we
want and we need to talk about for
example if it's money or if it's health
or if we're not feeling really great
then we can talk about what it feels
like to be really well instead of
talking about not being well right
because if we're talking about not being
well we're attracting more of that more
of that more of that right and so that's
basically law of attraction I mean it is
so wonderful and it's so intricate and
the more that
you the more that it becomes a part of
your life the more you see the little
kind of twists and turns synchronicities
yeah like for for example if if if you
saying yeah I'm so overwhelmed there's
just so much going on at the moment and
I can't get on top of things and I'm
just
overwhelmed guess what guess what's
coming more overwhelmed
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is speak the
language of money with Cody Sanchez if
you speak the language of money you
usually make more of it man this one is
so true there's a bunch of words they
use in finance that take people from
really really rich to outside of the
loop entirely most of us don't speak the
language of finance and I think that's
on purpose I think people in finance do
not want you to know the secrets to
wealth because that makes it easier for
them to keep it but there are so many
terms eida Roi cash on cash return
expense ratio the list goes on and on
and on actually there's a whole article
here on it if you want it but if you
actually want to get real wealth you
have to learn the main terms it's pretty
easy to do actually you could take a
couple courses on YouTube but this was
actually told to me by one of the
wealthiest Partners uh at Goldman Sachs
they came down in the beginning and did
a little lunch and learn with us when I
was at the firm and we were asking a
bunch of questions and he was using
jargon iida for instance and I remember
one of the people in the room raised
their hands and they said what does the
term ibaa mean can you explain that and
he kind of looked at the person with
like snoody Goldman air as we did and
said I don't know how you got a job at
this firm without speaking the language
of money that term exactly the language
of money and he said you go find the
answer to that I'm not here to be your
dictionary and it was such a perfectly
Goldman response but actually he was
right and so it always stuck with me
learn the terms then you can make the
cash rule number five is stop being a
victim with Robin charma the words you
use really are like a context or a
framework or a stained glass window on
the way you see the world I mean here's
a game-changing Insight you see the
world not as it is you see the World As
You Are
you see the world through a lens and
your language forms that lens of belief
I mean your lens of belief and your
personal filter on reality is not really
a true filter on reality it's just the
filter on reality that has formed as a
result of all the words you've picked up
from the moment you were born so when
you were a little baby your mom and your
dad use the language that they were
taught when they were kids to use and if
they use the language of victimitis and
if they use the language of victimhood
like well you know you can't do this I
hate this I'm tired of this money
doesn't grow on trees be ordinary if
you're successful you'll be hated all
that messaging that we pick up from our
parents and the media and the world
around us and our peers the little kids
that we used to play with in the
playground or the friends that we had as
teenagers that will either Lift us up or
tear us down
so I guess what I'm trying to say and
hopefully I'm making the point clearly
for you but we see the world through
this personal filter and a lot of this
personal filter that drives our
performance and our behavior is really
constructed from the words that we've
picked up and then the words we are
taught to use and so the right angle
turn for you to create exponential
energy mindset productivity creativity
results in the world results in your
life comes down to in part a really
intelligent use of your words and like I
said at the beginning of this Mastery
session most people are really
unconscious about their words and that's
why most people are not getting rare
eror results so what are some of the
words I encourage you to shift from well
don't talk about what you hate to do
talk about what you love to do don't
talk about problems talk about
opportunities don't talk about what
makes you tired talk about what makes
you inspired TI don't talk about your
past talk about your future don't talk
about what broke you your heart talk
about what opened your heart don't talk
about what disp Spirits you talk about
what you are fueled by don't talk about
the things within your life that are not
working talk about the things in your
life that are working don't talk about
your pain talk about your pleasure and
you know if I if I were sitting with you
right now coaching you I mean I am
coaching you and what I would encourage
you to do as soon as I finish this
Mastery session is pull out your journal
and if you're not journaling please
start journaling because journaling is a
ritual you want to install into your
Days Joan didan said this I don't know
what I think until I write it
down think about that I don't know what
I think until I write it down and so in
your Journal after this Mastery session
pull out a fresh page and draw a line
down the center of the page and write
about the language of victimhood and the
language of leadership
leadership and start to write down all
the words you use and the sentences you
employ that really are speaking that are
really victim speak and then in the
other column I want you to start writing
down the language of leadership the
language that as of today you will be
committed to using so that you start to
use the language of someone who's world
class and I've given you some examples
but doing that exercise will make it
really clear and as you know Clarity
breeds Mastery bottom line is this you
are built to be a leader you are not
constructed to be a victim and once you
get your words right you are going to
start noticing daily shifts in your
energy your focus your momentum your
confidence and your output and when you
start getting those words right you
start lifting your professional life
your personal life to a whole new level
of wow and guess what that is what you
are meant to do rule number six is start
thinking positively with Lewis house
when you talk about gossip and you talk
about bad news and you talk about
comparison and judgment and anxiety and
stress that feeds in a community of
other people that speak in the same
language so you want to shift your
language and start thinking more
positively and if you feel like you
aren't deserving of a loving
relationship a loving partner you're
most likely going to attract the wrong
type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail you're not
going to be able to focus your energy on
the right clients or the products that
will take your business to the next
level or the skills you need to develop
to help you grow now your thoughts
dictate your actions and where your
energy goes so you want to be thinking
about what can I do to replace these
negative thoughts the anxiousness or the
fear how can I replace it so my energy
can go in any more positive direction
and again where you put your energy into
is what you
attract so if you're thinking negative
thoughts all day long you're probably
going to attract that if you're thinking
gratitude and positive thoughts you'll
start to see that show up differently
and number seven the last room before
some very special bonus Clips is improve
your body language with Dr Amy cudy I
ask people to do a kind of audit of
their body of of how they're holding
holding themselves and it's funny when I
when I'm giving a talk and speaking to a
big group of people and I say you know
now check your posture I can hear
everyone immediately moving in their
chairs you even if the lights are low
but I say no don't move yet check your
posture because what you think you think
that when you're not the one
performing it your body language doesn't
matter because you again we're think we
think of body language as Just One
Direction what we're saying to others
but our body language is always always
speaking to us as well so I ask them to
think to to pay attention to what is
their default even just seated position
are they holding their shoulders up and
forward collapsing their chests are they
wrapping their hands or arms around
their torso or what the marks of
powerlessness so like what's the it
really is you know your your limbs are
pulled in your shoulders are pull pulled
forward your chest is collapsed um legs
might be crossed and ankles wrapped I
think the wrapping of the ankles matters
more than the crossing of the legs if
you watch sports and watch what's
happening what what what is the winning
team doing versus the losing
team you really see it I mean you see
you know these big basketball players
who are holding their heads in their
hands and you know leaning forward and
and they they look absolutely defeated
um even though they're they're just as
physically strong as they were 5 minutes
earlier when things were going well so
watching the body language of like
athletes for example and then paying
attention to what you're doing yourself
I think helps us to become much more
aware of how we're carrying ourselves
but you can do little things like just
when you get up in the morning you know
if you wake up all curled up in the
fetal position which is the most common
sleeping position 40% of people sleep in
the fetal position and we know that when
people wake up in the fetal position um
they are more anxious than people who
don't that is obviously correlational we
don't know the the causal Direction
because it might be that you're anxious
and that's why you're sleeping in the
fetal position nonetheless say you wake
up in the fetal position stretch out you
know into a starfish pose you know be
you sayane bold in bed before you put
your feet on the gra on the ground one
of my research assistants said that he
would uh hold one of his hands on his
hip while he brushed his teeth like
little things that like that that sort
of forced him to spend a little bit of
time
expanding really helped and I hear so
many stories like this people rearrange
their desks so that they have to stretch
out a bit more when they're working
instead of you know working like this
over their phone you know how are you
sitting in your car are you you know
really close to the steering wheel and
kind of collapsed or more open little
things like that can really change the
way you feel so I think it starts with
just noticing how we carry ourselves how
we carry ourselves physically how we
speak how we
breathe you have the power to control
your world how you think how you act
your mindset with the words that you
speak when you use weak language you
signal to yourself that you are weak you
signal to yourself that your goals
aren't important you signal to yourself
that you are not worth it you lose
respect for yourself and the people
around you don't respect you either we
need to stop using weak language and pay
attention to the words that you're
speaking to others and to yourself now
this is not an easy task because most of
the words that you're using the way that
you talk to others and to yourself
you're on autopilot you're on cruise
control it just happens you've been
doing this for years or decades and so
switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that I'm going to
share with you it can have a joke
dramatic impact on your self-confidence
on the goals that you have for yourself
and on the outcomes you create for
yourself in the world let's do it number
one I can't I'm not I don't what you say
after those three things shapes your
identity it speaks to how you think and
speak about yourself so I can't I can't
be an entrepreneur I can't be a leader I
can't be a YouTuber I can't I can't I
can't I can't I can't especially this
one when you say I can't pay very very
very very very very close attention to
what follows and try and try and try to
shift it from I can't to either I choose
not to or I can't yet I'm not I'm not a
good sales person I'm not funny I'm not
the kind of person who follows through
again pay close attention and try to
shift it to not yet I don't I don't
program I don't know how to make money I
don't think like that switch I don't to
I don't yet I can't I'm not I don't
those statements are final those
statements don't allow for growth those
statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary or change them to yet number
two is catch your cruise control the way
that you have been speaking about
yourself the way that you have been
talking to yourself has been happening
using the same words for years maybe
even decades it's so automatic for you
you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just Auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99% of these moments of these
words of these languages that you using
for yourself but if you have the
awareness if you have the intention if
you have the desire every now and then
you will catch it another quick hack is
to enlist a friend enlist the people
around you your wife your husband your
team your kids kids especially my son
Hayden loves calling me out on things
enlist their help tell them this is
where I want to play a bigger game this
is where I'm frustrated with myself this
is where I keep talking badly about
myself and putting myself down these are
the words the language that need to
change and every time you hear me
talking this way I need you to bring it
to my awareness and let me know cuz I
want to catch my cruise control for me
personally it's around complaining
anytime I complain I want my wife I want
my team I want my son I want the people
around me to say Evan you are
complaining right there that was a
complaint eat it right I'm happy for
them to hug me with it to yell at me
with it I just want them to let me know
now when I told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know awesome thank thank you I'm humbled
but I still complain and I probably
complain a lot and a lot of the times
I'm missing it and so please please
please please please please please even
if you think I'm great at it if you
catch me complaining I want you to call
me out on it so enlisting your friends
can be really helpful cuz you will
likely not catch most of them yourself
but it's imperative that you start
working on catching your cruise control
step number three is manual override you
have caught your cruise control you have
found the autopilot it's about to happen
again this negative talk that you're
about to speak out into the world about
yourself or your ideas you putting
yourself down is about to come out again
or has just come out what do you do
about it because this is really
important if you catch yourself playing
small or talking negatively about
yourself if you catch it and you don't
do anything it actually makes it worse
it's better that you don't even catch it
at all if you catch it and you recognize
I am playing small right now and you
ignore it and you you don't change your
behavior you are building that identity
for yourself that you are somebody who
is playing small you are consciously
building that identity for yourself and
you need to stop it it makes it
worse where when you do catch it when
you find yourself falling into those
patterns those behaviors that you don't
want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it what do you do you need to kick
your manual override into action and
take the action that you want cuz starts
building the positive habit that starts
building the positive respect this is
how you build respect for yourself this
is how you start building the muscle
this isn't just a zero sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral when
you catch it you either go sliding down
or you go propelling up the choice is
yours when you catch yourself playing
small when you catch yourself coming off
of cruise control you have to do the
thing that builds the self respect up
and speak positively about yourself and
do the thing that you are scared to do
see this
line that's called The Terror barrier
yeah jumping at you isn't it and on the
other side of the terror barrier is
something we call
Freedom and you know very few people get
through that Terror barrier it's rather
sad freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone that canot live the
way they want to
live
see why don't they why don't
they they don't know and they don't even
know they don't know now I'm going to
show you why people experience buyer
remorse when they buy something they
really want then they back away or they
go to move and they don't they go to
change jobs and they don't they go to
move to another city and they don't why
fear causes them to stay where they
are there's the individual the X
represents the unknown factor the
Paradigm now there's a power flowing
into this individual's mind and they can
make anything out of it they want
remember we said we had the ability to
choose what do they choose they choose
thoughts that are in harmony with the
Paradigm now here's an important point
the paradig controls the vibration of
this thing we call our body our body is
a molecular instrument that's really
what it is it's a mass of molecules and
a very high speed of vibration the
vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call
feeling when a person says they feel
this way or they feel that way what
they're really doing is describing the
vibration they're in now they choose
thoughts that harmonize with the
vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're
comfortable now let's move ahead
let's take a look here those people are
getting xtype results and they don't
like it do you know what the problem
with them they're in bondage these
people are locked
up you
know Paradigm is like keeping a person
in a prison only there's no locks on the
door they can open the prison to walk
out into Freedom anytime they want and
they don't they keep getting the same
results over and over and over again
they're in bondage now let's go ahead
here's the same person X Type lening ex
tight vibration the power is flowing
into them and for some strange reason
from Left Field b boom incomes A Y type
idea what is the Y type idea the Y type
idea represents anything that you might
want to do that you're not doing it
might be moved to another city change
jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may
be ask the little girl for the date ask
the guy to go to lunch
go make the
sale buy what you want go where you want
to go that's the why idea but as long as
the why idea is just in the conscious
mind it's just going to be an
intellectual exercise it's never going
to
happen so how do we make it happen well
that's when everything goes haywire here
we are here same person okay the power
flows in and what do they do they got
the Y type idea now for some strange
reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved that they're going
to act on that idea they don't
understand what's going to happen but
clearly understand this your central
nervous system is the most complex
electrical system in the
universe the central nervous
system is mindboggling it would make the
electrical system and a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subjective mind that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an ex XY vibration it's not
in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable no on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt
the doubt turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as
anxiety see that person is getting
emotionally involved to move ahead do
you know what happens they hit that
Terror barrier and they bounce off it
and right back into
bondage and they're so relieved to get
back
there they're back where they're
comfortable they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move they're
going to stay in the job that they don't
like at least they're
comfortable now that's not a very good
way to live and you know something
that's something everybody experiences
if they're going to grow you're going to
hit that Terror barrier see the terror
barrier is going Beyond where you're at
going to a new level I'm going to tell
you something when I set a goal if if if
it doesn't scare and excite me at the
same time I know I'm going in the wrong
direction now I also understand that my
Paradigm is going to try and get me to
bounce back to where I was it doesn't
want me to move ahead
I don't want to live there I lived there
for the first 26 years of my life and
for the last 50 I've had a phenomenal
life and it just keeps getting better
and I want you to do the same thing
understand what I've just said I'm going
to back this up they got emotionally
involved in the why idea that moved
their body into a different vibration on
a conscious level they're experiencing
some crazy stuff they start to doubt
their ability they'll never be able to
pay for it they they experience fear the
fear expresses itself as
anxiety and bang you bounce off that
Terror barrier and you're right back oh
I might not be earning much here but I
know what it is I I I would love to move
there but I'm comfortable here I think
I'll just stay here these people are
acting like they have a contract to live
forever and they don't do you know what
to do say I'm going to get rid of all
that I understand it's there but I don't
want any part of it and I'm going to go
crashing right through that Terror
barrier now does that get rid of the X
energy no the X
energy is still there you see but at
least you're over into Freedom you made
the move you did it and if you continue
to feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go
away and you know where you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to
live buyer's
remorse is when you cancel the
sale buyer's remorse is when you stop
just before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know
it it's not moving to the other city
it's not starting the business of your
dreams it's not stepping out and betting
on
yourself that's a terror barrier that's
causing that and if you don't learn to
go through the terror barrier I'm going
to tell you something you're going to
stay right where you are for the rest of
your days that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell
say so
true the cave you fear to enter holds
the treasure you seek I know you all
have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do You' got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create to
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being being but all of that is
impossible without great habits setup if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you you'll fall off and and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge I
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you can't keep the Habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
more on more regular basis and then it
goes away or you say you know I'm going
to be more kind and more patient and
more awesome to my partner my lover and
you start being nice for two or three
days and then on the fourth day you're a
jerk you know and you're like what what
happened I said I was going to be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments you
have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
a better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision your journal or set up on a
vision board that you look at once in a
while but in daytoday life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this is going to be so basic basic
you're going to laugh and then I'll also
tell you how I've literally taught this
to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it was
the one thing that changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with this let's I have a goal in mind
let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you could meditate in the morning
say today I'm going to be more present
and calm and you you could you can start
out with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said close
your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 600 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've Ted to do this
hundreds of thousands and they tell me
all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer
and more present close my eyes take 10
deep breaths reground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm so for
example for me on the opposite Spectrum
I don't want to just be calmer and more
present I Want More Energy throughout
the day so here's what I do one of my
big trigger moments is every time time
my butt hits a chair I don't care if I'm
on a plane or I was like where we're
shooting here I I wrote a lot of my
books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercis just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just two to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that 2 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah you
know why because I've triggered my day
so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
doorframe triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat
off immediately in my mind because I've
done it so many times consciously I went
to the door I said the three words said
the three words said the three words and
I did this so many times that now when I
walk through a door my mind
automatically triggers those three words
and I remember to be those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach executives do this as well
I have them have a doorframe trigger
when they walk into their office in the
morning as soon as they walk through
that door frame they have boom three
words go through their mind about how
they want to be perceived as a leader I
have them set up another door every time
they walk into a meeting into the
conference room when they walk through
the doors of the conference room they
have another three words that trigger
off for them and it just reminds them
how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
your diet is one of the most important
things that you can do to boost your
energy your focus and your productivity
what you should be eating varies wildly
and I will just tell you right now that
while I'm going to give you a very
simple thing that you can follow and
it's going to take care of 80% of all of
your desires and problems no that there
is massive variability at the individual
level and that you should be testing a
lot of different things to find out what
is right for you so what I'm about to
lay out is the sort of generic strategy
that I think everybody should try but
getting into the nitty-gritty is going
to require you to do a lot of testing
there is no way around this I wish that
dieting was more simplistic but based on
your life style based on your heredity
based on your microbiome all of this
stuff is going to dramatic to dramatic
ically vary so be very thoughtful make
sure you run experimentation having said
that what are the things that I think
are Universal number one you want to be
eating Whole Food whenever humanly
possible so you want to eat food that is
recognizable from what it was in nature
so a piece of meat should look like a
piece of meat it shouldn't be highly
processed your vegetabl should look like
vegetables and you should be brushing
dirt off of them that kind of
recognizable from nature nuts should be
I mean ideally raw I'll be really honest
I do sometimes eat uh roasted nuts but
if I'm honest that's worse than if
you're just eating them raw so you want
things that are as close to um their
natural state is humanly possible the
less that they have been messed with
manufactured altered and anyway the
better off you're going to be I will say
that heat is something that I apply to
virtually all of my food there are some
really interesting theories about from
an evolutionary standpoint that cooking
is one of the things that allowed us to
grow the big brain because by cooking it
you not only soften the food make it
easier to chew but you also release some
of the nutrients it's beyond the scope
of uh this to get into that but when I
say raw I don't mean that everything
needs to be uncooked I just mean the
less processed the better things that I
eat every day I eat a lot of eggs red
meat I eat some chicken a bit of pork
but I'm eating a fair amount of meat so
I get a good portion of my calories from
that again individual variability if
you're doing a vegan thing word I'm
totally about it test for the individual
response that you get I find that the
more plant forward I go there's like a
breaking point where I start feeling
worse could be me it could be me doing
it poorly but as long as you're doing
whole food I think you're on the money
so eating whole food and making sure
that you're avoiding sugar that is like
the big thing so I don't think you can
eat fruit with impunity I think you have
to be very thoughtful about that if
you're unsure of what fruit is going to
impact you and how I highly recommend
getting a continuous glucose monitor
that will allow you to eat fruit if you
want and see what kind of of glycemic
response you have for instance I find
that I can make certain fruit smoothies
and if I eat it slowly enough my uh
glycemic response will go up to about
120 I prefer to keep it in the 80s but
hey if it goes up to 120 and it's sort
of even and it comes back down I don't
consider that too problematic but if I
eat it really quickly and it spikes up
to say 140 150 that to me is problematic
and I don't want to be that high so you
can play with things also what you put
in the Smoothie Etc if you're going to
eat fruit and vegetables make sure that
you separate fruit and vegetables keep
those two things distinct I think you
will find by wearing a continuous
glucose monitor that you're going to
have a dramatically different response
to most fruit than you will to
vegetables again there's a lot of
variability here so the more that you
test on yourself the better but that's
really the the sort of generic response
if you're or generic setup that I think
everybody should try whole food when
never humanly possible avoid sugar
keeping your blood glucose below 100 I
highly recommend it for me I try to keep
my glucose in this the 80ish range
that's sort of my default I also do
intermittent fasting I think that that
is very effective getting into things
like autophagy is beyond the scope of
what we're talking about right now but
even that I think is going to be huge
body composition is greatly affected by
intermittent fasting again individual
variability make sure that you
experiment with this stuff for yourself
I do when you average it out I think I
went about 18 months where I was
tracking every day my average over that
extended period of time was 17 and a
half hours so on the weekends it's it's
shorter but on the weekdays sometimes
it's longer sometimes it's 19 20 21 22
hours that I'll go uh between meals but
again over a very extended period of
time it averages out to 17 1/2 hours of
not eating now the way that I do that I
have my last meal around 1:15 definitely
done chewing by 2:00 p.m. and then I
don't eat again until the next day at
around 9 9:30 somewhere around in there
shorter on the weekends longer during
the week and it it balances out I'm
having everything from uh green leafy
vegetables like uh bok choy uh collored
greens kale broccoli um to carrot hikima
um I do occasionally have some sweet
potato it'll be a little thoughtful
about that one watch your glycemic load
that definitely spikes me more than
green leafy vegetables but those are the
mix that I use again I'm eating Whole
Foods virtually all of my calories come
from Whole Food uh during the week in
fact I'd say 95% of my calories come
from Whole Food it's very rare that I
deviate from that but doing that allows
me to have tremendous focus a lot of
energy get the most out of my workouts
maintain my body composition keep my fat
low keep my glycemic uh spikes low so
I'm not getting you know blood sugar
spikes which helps me maintain my energy
through the day and also just from a
longevity standpoint I think that's a
great idea I will say go look at David
Sinclair who's got some pretty
compelling information around the fact
that meat may not be great for longevity
so while it makes me feel awesome it's
something called mtor so be thoughtful
as you get into the complex weeds of
this stuff nutrition is a very big
complex topic again the only things that
I consider universals are whole food and
reducing sugar universals close to a
universal would be intermittent fasting
though some people can have differing
responses to that so be thoughtful as
you experiment with this stuff but if
you do that like I said 80 plus% of your
problems are going to go away that's a
nice low inflammation diet and keeping
your inflammation low is incredibly
important just give yourself
permission to want the things that you
want and unless you believe that you're
worthy unless that you practice love
you're never going to think that you
deserve the things that you want right
so tell the
story okay so I'm probably going to
hysterically I'll shorten it I'll
shorten it so the the Bott line is that
so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience that you may be able to
relate to and that is I walked in and I
immediately saw this painting hanging on
the wall and it was about the size of a
door only horizontal and it was a
Vermont landscape
and I was drawn into it immediately like
I was no longer in that restaurant I was
standing in that field I could feel that
breeze I'd never ever had an experience
like that with a painting have you ever
had an experience like that with art no
I mean not like that not like that I
mean my yeah my sense was that this is
very atypical for you very so
I kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then I leaned
back and suddenly kind of back in the
moment I'm like I'm going to own this
painting someday it just that was what
was right there and I looked at the
price and it said like $3,000 I'm like
not today and I went back and I sat down
and that was it but the painting never
left my mind you see there's something
called the zyen AR effect I I always say
it wrong but it's like there's a
checklist in your brain that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah there's like a notch yes
a notch happen and now your brain as
part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high-intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember so uh bottom
line is uh I always thought about that
painting years go by whenever somebody
would say Vermont I'd think of the
painting I don't know why I can't
explain it never wanted a painting
before was not an art student it's going
to law like you're out collecting art no
no no and so I you know fast forward the
story 10 years and my uh H Chris and I
are are engaged and we're going to go up
to Vermont to see the leaves and
immediately I'm like we got to go to
Simon Pierce I got to show you the
painting so we pull up to the mill and
we walk in and right in front there is
Boom a pain by the same artist Gail
Shephard and I'm like oh my God it's
here and we race all around the place
and it's gone and the funny thing was
and this is the way your brain works
Chris was more disappointed than I was I
literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm going to
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
Chris I'm going to be able to buy this
like 40 years from now it's going to be
hanging in the corporate Lobby of some
building and I'm going to have to track
down the owner and pay like quadruple
the money they pay but I'm going to own
this Mission yes so a couple years pass
and um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people
to give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had I had
what 500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid I should have
bought a crib or stools but for whatever
reason the zigen arch effact takes over
and I'm like the painting so I call the
mill and I get this guy on the phone I'm
like uh you know I want to buy a kale
Shephard piece and I said could you send
me Polaroids and he's like sure and I
tell him the budget and he goes I'll
I'll send you Polaroids of some of her
smaller
things and CU she's like blowing up in
the meantime right yeah she's a very
very successful Vermont landscape artist
and so
I I I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting and I describe
the painting I had seen over 10 years
ago and he said 'w that was way before
my time but I bet Gail will know and I'm
like Gail you know Gail he's like of
course I know Gail she like lives in in
down the road here's her number so for
two days I paced around the apartment
with 500 bucks in my pocket driving
Chris crazy cuz I felt like what am I
going to say to her and I must be a
weirdo I've been stalking this lady I've
been thinking about her for 10 years I
can't afford a painting you know what
who am I to buy a painting like what the
hell so finally Chris is like would you
call her I'm going to call her you're
driving me crazy so I call her and I
start talking a mile a minute and she
was
amazing and then um I said by the way
there was this one painting and I go and
I explain this painting there is a stand
of popler trees down the center and a
big mountain scape behind it and this
beautiful blue Vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and I could
hear her thinking on the other end of
the line and she said you know Mel I've
done so many large
scale uh paintings over the years I'd
hate to mistake the one you're talking
about but I'll tell you what what if my
husband and I meet you and Chris at the
Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll walk all
around and have lunch and I'll tell you
the stories behind every painting and if
you don't see what you like there I'll
take you back to my studio which is a
couple miles down the river and you can
look at everything I'm working on and if
you don't see anything you like there
then you can go through all my slides
and see if you can find that painting
that you saw 10 years ago and I said
deal so a month passes we go up to the
mill I walk in we meet each other she's
amazing she's like twice our age just
incredibly cool lady she's walking
around as we're walking around looking
at these paintings Rich I've got I'm
like eight months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I
have I can't afford this like I don't I
don't have this kind of
money and I'm getting getting like more
and more into that impostor syndrome
what am I doing mode oh my God I'm so
embarrassed I'm meeting somebody I
idolize I don't deserve to be here right
wasting her time because she thinks
she's going to get a Payday out of this
correct we sit down and she goes now
that you're sitting down I have
something to tell
you
um she said there's only been two times
in my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
piece and your painting is one of them
it's one of a
pair she knew all along she knew all
along she was playing games with you
about not knowing which painting yeah
and she said the sister piece to the one
that you saw all those years ago is
sitting in my studio right now where
it's been for the past 11
years I start sobbing everybody's like
totally emotional her husband's like you
should have seen her when you when she
was on the phone with you it was like
she saw a ghost so we get in the car and
we drive to the mill and when we walk in
there in the center of this massive kind
of Barn Studio space is an easel with a
painting taped up with painters tape on
it and it was the sister to my painting
there were slight differences not as
much movement in the grass but it
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was standing before that
painting in
1990 saying it would be mine and there I
was 11 years
later standing in front of it and then I
realized oh my God I can't
afford this and Chris walks over and
he's like what's wrong and I'm like just
promise me someday like promise me that
I don't need a a jewelry I don't need a
like just promise me you will buy me
this thing and he kind of leans over and
goes hey Gail how much for the big one
and she said um Mel can have it for 500
bucks cuz clearly when I was making it
11 years ago I was making it for
her
yeah and so it hangs in my kitchen it's
on the back of the book um this is the
galley though right so wait is it in the
is it in I think so yeah yeah and um
it's a reminder every day that your mind
is designed to help you get what you
want I never stop believing that I could
make it happen and when you tell your
mind what's important to you there is
extraordinary
science that proves that your mind has a
live and everchanging filter a live
Network that changes how it views the
world what lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you
want because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for The Ultimate Guide to
improve your communication skills check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there in everything you do
then to learn how to communicate nobody
is going to care or listen to you and
the Very nature of influence and impact
which is the leader's job